tout
papa combats pros combattre ou à québec
s'acquitte tac tic tac tac tic tac
bon bon bon bon bon bon bon
j'espère que vous avez tous compris ce
langage si c'est pas le cas on va
essayer de vous expliquer en fait on va
prendre le langage suivant pour mon
pauvre
bon ben vous avez compris je vous parle
du langage du coeur du coeur physique et
vous avez le bruit vous savez que le
coeur ça s'écoute ça s'écoute avec cet
instrument qu'on appelle un stéthoscope
et vous avez tous je suis sûre dans
cette salle une fois eu une auscultation
par votre médecin ou demandant mais
qu'est ce qui peut bien entendre qu'est
ce qui peut bien écouter sur mes poumons
ou sur mon coeur est bien haut les
stéthoscopes est une vieille histoire
mais avant les stéthoscopes n'oubliez
pas que les médecins auscultait en
posant leurs oreilles sur la poitrine
des gens après avoir mis un petit linge
en coton il ausculte est et puis en 1816
l'edhec a réussi ce prodige de créer le
premier trait stéthoscope
vous l'avez sous les yeux c'est un tube
rigide et depuis les choses ont évolué
vers des instruments beaucoup beaucoup
plus précis pendant longtemps on n'avait
que cela pour faire un diagnostic et des
affections cardiaques fin des années 70
début des années 80 arid une technique
fantastique ce sont les ultrasons du
coeur
l'échocardiographie probablement
beaucoup de personnes entre vous ont
déjà eu cet examen
l'échocardiographie c'est une révolution
dans le domaine de la cardiologie ça
nous permet de voir enfin des structures
de manière très précise de calculer des
volumes des débits vous avez un exemple
des images qu'on peut avoir mais
imaginez vous que tout ça bouge que les
flux que voyant couleurs vont dans
l'essence dans un sens ou dans un autre
en fonction de leur direction et qu'en
plus on compliquer le tout par un effet
doppler donc ceux qui ont déjà eu cet
examen c'est des couleurs c'est des
bruits et tout ça nous permet d'arriver
à un diagnostic très précis
l'échocardiographie que vous avez sous
les yeux est pour moi un souvenir et bus
vendredi soir un jeune garçon vous est
adressée par son médecin traitant parce
que il l'a trouvé une arythmie une
arythmie un peu particulière et nous dit
écoute je suis embêté et doit faire un
match de ce qu est ok ce week-end je
vois rien d'autre il en électro normal
il n'occulte à sion normal est ce que tu
pourrais pas le voir et nous l'avons
convoqué le vendredi soir en fait il
n'avait pas un écolo un déclic trop
normale n'avait pas non plus une
auscultation normal mais c'est toujours
difficile pour un non spécialiste en
réalité où nous avons fait d'emblée une
échographie et nous avons eu la
désagréable surprise de constater qu'il
avait un coeur totalement dilater avec
une fraction d'éjection de 10% fraction
d'éjection ça vous dit peut-être rien
mais quand vous avez un coeur qui se
contracte à peu près comme ça ce qu'on
dit bon vieux et doit voir lui le
vainqueur qui faisait sa gens qu'ils se
contractent et comme il avait des
arythmies qui était potentiellement
dangereuses
nous avons alors décidé de
l'hospitaliser et très rapidement nous
l'avons envoyé dans un service
universitaire pour qu'il puisse être un
tout petit peu suivie et confirme le
diagnostic que nous avions fait qu est
un diagnostic de mauvais pronostic
le diagnostic a été confirmé il a reçu
un traitement très lourd
et puis il est revenu chez nous on l'a
suivi
un jour il a fait de tels arythmique on
a dû implanter un défibrillateur en même
temps qu un pacemaker un peu particulier
dans ses piles qui sont devenus de plus
en plus intelligentes pour essayer de
rattraper un peu son coeur finalement la
situation s'est dégradée de plus en plus
et on a dû mettre transitoirement une
pompe pour aider son coeur jusqu'au jour
où ils l'auraient une transplantation
il a eu une transplantation est
malheureusement
24 10 dt c'est triste c'est toujours du
mal à accepter
il avait 22 ans ceci me permet
maintenant de dali sur un ou une autre
partie de ma présentation en faites ce
que je vous ai montré c'est que le coeur
il nous parle le curry nous dit des tas
de choses nous souvent beaucoup plus
parce que quand on suit pendant 30 ou 40
ans les gens je peux vous assurer que
non seulement leur coeur nous parle non
seulement le coeur physique mais l'autre
aussi c est ce que votre coeur vous pas
l'excusé déjà pensé si votre coeur vous
parle souvent il est muet puis vous êtes
là vous sentez rien puis un jour vous
avez eu un stress une émotion ses fans
et de zinc ou santé pom pom pom pom
tiens j'ai mon coeur j'ai un coeur j'ai
un truc qui bat un peu fort un peu vite
c'est embêtant bon c'est pas grave vous
êtes tous compris qu'il n'y a aucun
problème à faire une chose pareille a
traité mais peut-être qu'en soir alors
que vous êtes au lit ou bien vous êtes
assis sur un fauteuil tout à coup vous
avez pas vous ah il ya mon coeur qui
s'arrête ou bien qu'un j'ai une ratée
supplémentaire qu'est ce qu'ils achètent
et qu'est ce que ça vous vous levez en
général c'est ce qui se passe on va à la
fenêtre respire profondément chavas pis
on se dit mais tu nous tiens mon coeur
il est en train de me parler
qu'est ce qui va me raconter le coeur de
sa vie c'est un organe assez spécial on
en lira de mots tout à l'heure c'est un
organe qui comporte deux systèmes très
performants un système électrique et un
système pour alimenter le muscle
cardiaque en oxygène des systèmes
électriques c'est les faisceaux de
conduction et le les systèmes pour
amener l'oxygène ce sont les coronaires
système électrique
il est très performant mais de temps en
temps idéal et probablement dans cette
salle c'est difficilement possible que
c'est pas le cas il ya des gens qui un
jour en tout deux que vous leur coeur
s'accélère en grand pompe en 150 est
ensuite arrivé vers un coeur qui est
irrégulier et puis des fois ça passe et
des fois il faut appeler le médecin il
faut aller à l'hôpital etc
il ya des examens
il ya un autre système qui est encore
plus embêtant et normalement sur 900
personnes et devrait bien avoir une ou
deux qui l'ont eu ça c'est le coeur avec
un système d'offres tout à coup le coeur
s'accélère monde il part à 150 200 250
ça dure dix secondes 20 secondes des
fois deux minutes et les gens sont un
peu épuisés quand ils ans et ils ont des
douleurs à la poitrine y sont pas très
contents
dans cette situation il est clair que
vous devez consulter pour au moins 6
dans les deux premières situations
y'a rien là avait il faut s'en fichent
simplement être sûr que votre coeur
n'est pas une anomalie qui nécessiterait
un traitement une autre situation vos
coeurs hotspur vous parle vous êtes un
jour en promenade avec des amis et ce
qui se passe vous voyez que tout d'un
coup vous n'arrivez plus à les suivre
ben oui c'est un peu du mal à souffler
rocher parce que je fume c'est parce que
j'ai pris du poids se résumait pas
d'entraînement c'est peut-être tout ça
mais ça pourrait aussi être que ce soit
un problème cardiaque
alors il faut pas s'inquiéter mais quand
même si après ça continue quand vous
entendez et sky et vous arrivez au
premier étage
bon d'accord on s'arrête deux minutes et
on repart c'est probablement que au
niveau du coeur ça ne suit pas le coeur
il peut ne pas être malade mettant
entend s'exprimer avec un peu de peine
et vous parlez vous dites attention là
peut-être ta force et peut-être a fait
quelque chose et puis deux autres
situations et j'en termine avec avec ce
parti du coeur à savoir ce que la
deuxième situation
c'est une douleur qui apparaît quand
vous faites un effort
souvent première fois c'est l'hiver les
foules en paix dans la neige bien vous
avez une douleur pis c'est gênant ça
vous prend la partie remonte un peu dans
le coup c'est malin
dans le bras gauche la main gauche enfin
bref ça c'est peut-être le signe que une
de vos coronaire est en train de se
boucher est dans cette situation de
grâce consulter et enfin la dernière
situation où le coeur n'est pas content
et où vraiment il vous dit maintenant il
faut que tu te bouges c'est une fois
cette douleur est là elle persiste
sarris très souvent la nuit ou au petit
matin
et là il ya indications parce qu'au bout
de 5 minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes elle
est toujours là
il ya indications a appelé le médecin le
samu et s'il fait de diagnostic
d'infarctus il pourra vous conduire dans
un hôpital dans un service d'urgence où
vous aurez une dilatation ces petits
ballonnets puis ces petites sources
qu'on m'ait qu'on appelle des systèmes
auv où le billet mais pourquoi je vous
raconte tout ça tout ça vous en avez
entendu parler selon bain parce que le
coeur c'est en fait un miracle permanent
regardez le battre le coeur y pèse entre
250 et 350 g synchro bifteck et il se
contracte en moyenne cent mille fois par
jour
c'est pas mal pour un débit de 5000 gîte
rendez compte que ça représente 5000
litres par jour ça veut dire que si on
avait branché tous vos coeurs avec un
petit tuyau épi qui débite en continu et
qu'on ait mis un grand bassin de l'autre
côté ben le temps de cette présentation
on aurait rempli un bassin de quarante
mille litres
c'est pas mal ce qui pour un homme de 70
ans ça représente l'équivalent de 2500
wagon-citerne de 60 mille litres
c'est un train qui fait belfort au delà
de besançon deux wagons-citernes
ininterrompue voilà le travail que fait
votre coeur et voilà le message que je
voulais vous montrer ce petit organe qui
travaillent tellement mais les reviews
mans donc il faut en prendre soin il
faut le protéger et peut-être savoir
l'écouter mais donc savoir en prendre
soin et en prendre soin c'est lutter
contre les facteurs de risque et vous
les connaissez tous il y en a deux
sortes ya ce qu'on peut pas changer pour
l'instant c'est l'âge et l'hérédité et
puis il ya le diabète l'hypertension
l'hypercholestérolémie le tabac la
malbouffe l'obésité la sédentarité et
c'est à vous en entendez toujours parler
mais ça mérite quand même qu'on leur
contrôle parce que le coeur a quand même
beaucoup de choses à vous dire
il faut simplement savoir l'écouter
voilà ce n'est pas un message très long
mais c'est le message que je voulais
vous prononcer et puis
suite
avant avant sus de terminer quand même
je ne vous ai pas parlé du langage des
émotions du coeur des émotions c'est
quand même un grand chapitre mais je le
réserve à d'autres je suis peut-être pas
suffisamment compétent mais je me
rappelle quand même la phrase de pascal
le coeur a ses raisons que la raison ne
connaît pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]